Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to the expert levels in Super Mario Maker!
And the Hundred Mario Challenge! That we're doing right now!
Ohh God, oh God, oh God, oh gosh-y gosh!
Okay, we're fine
Ow
Why are you following me?!
Why was he following me?! I--
Oh! Why-- I pushed the button!
Okay, we're going to try that again, because apparently this is going absolutely bonkers insane.
Hep.
Get down.
You don't deserve to be flying.
Okay, here we go.
Try this again.
Oh
Nice
Very nice
Op!
Alright
Okay
Woah, hey now.
Woah, hey now!
Come on, now!
Woo!
Oh, shit.
Dammit!
I... was doing the 'P' flying, I was flying with my 'P'
Dammit, okay
But at least I got the checkpoint there.
So I need to use--
Oww-ee!
Holy balls!
Alright, I forgot about them.
Ah!
Oh.
Uh.
So scary.
Hep.
Boink!
There's nice, that's nice
That's what I call nice
Hop
Okay, do I need to take this with me?
Do I need to take this with me?
Is that what I need to do?
M-A-R
O-I?
Maroi?
Who's Maroi?!
What's Maroi mean?!
Who the heck is Maroi?!
I don't know what that means but someone needs to correct their spelling...
...and go back to school.
Anyway, I did that! So that's good.
And I got the world record!
Nice!
What a nice, lovely introduction to this.
I don't know if I got any...
1-Ups on that one, but...
At least I didn't lose too many lives. 87 and 8 levels--
Pf, wow I can't do math. 12 levels left to go.
"Cloud is the Way".
Cloud is the way?
Oopsie-poopsie I didn't know that was gonna be--
Okay, so I gotta be more patient
Or I gotta be faster!
Hah! Hehehe
You thought you could beat me?
The answer was you were, you were not...
Gonna beat me.
Boink.
Okay.
So cloud is the answer.
I'm not 100% sure... what that means...
And frankly, I, I don't really wanna know.
But...
Okay.
Everything's fine.
Everything's fine. Everything is going swimmingly for me.
Who wants some?!
Nobody here.
Maybe if I... can I bop these and take 'em? Nah.
They're still filled with animal.
Oh God, oh God!
Oh gosh.
Hogarth hughes!
Hog Hog?
Hog Hog?!
Woah- Ah, you didn't tell me there was gonna be something up there!
What a load of ass bag!
See now, we should be able to get by... this...
I don't... what was up there?
What was up there that hit me?!
You're just a load of bollocks!
Just--oh, that thing.
Whatever that is. It's 'cause I was going too slow.
At least I still got my--move!
Thank you for that.
Thank you for the boosh.
I didn't need to be booshed...
I've been booshed enough in my life.
I didn't even need that... why did I get that?
Why am I chasing after--cloud is the way.
I seem to be--
Okay.
Woah, hey, don't, don't ruin my cloud.
Okay--oh, I need to book it.
I am... too slow.
Gotta go fast.
Shit, did I--
Ah, come on!
Ah! I shoulda jumped, I didn't--
Why didn't I jump?!
Woah, woah, woah, woah
Still a little precarious on that launching sequence.
Once again I would like to reiterate that how unnecessary it actually is.
Off we go!
No time to waste!
We're going! We're gunning. We're gunning. We're gunning. We're gunning.
Oh god.
This was a mistake but it's okay 'cause I need this.
to last as long as possible.
Ok.  Going, going, going, -- going, going, going
Oh shit. Oh God, oh God, oh God
We're okay.
I don't know why those things are able to fly.
I mean, they're not even flying they're just kinda going...
Okay
This is good
Yes!
Yeeaahhh!
[random noises]
Yes!
I got a 1-Up.
Oof. This is getting difficult.
I mean it was difficult before but now it's actually
getting to the point where it's stressing me.
'Cause I can make it through this
I can make it through this but when it gets down
to the wire it's going to get pretty bad towards
the end of this game.
When I get to like level 12 and 13 I'm gonna be
sweating bullets if I keep losing lives like this.
Or if I run into another one that looks like the one
that I came into the first time I played this in the, two episodes ago.
HIIIII!
Oh god!
[Nervous laugh]
AHHHH!
Ohh! Why??
That's hardly fair!
What do I do about that? Eughhhh!
It's just gonna end in my death
Ahh! It's just my death!
Alright you know what? I'm not going through the door.
I'm not gonna play your game, you rogue!
I'm gonna play MY game!
And that game is Mario Maker.
Alright! Well that worked out wonderfully.
You'd better not be-
Whoa.
Woahohkay. Alright.
Okay.
Oh hi!
Ohh goodbye! Okay.
So do I go through that?
Or do I go up?
Oh that's, that's, that's quick timing.
Eugh.
Hep! Oh frick.
Aw fuck.
Okay, I can get this.
Gaaaah so close!
Dammit, too late!
Hup! There we go.
Hap! Goodbye!
I don't know where I'm supposed to be going with this.
Frankly, I don't think that I was supposed to be able to conquer this this quickly.
Oh boy.
Okay, goodbye.
Ohhh I'll take it!
You know what? I ain't complainin'
I-I'll take it
I'll take it, it's cool, it's fine with me
I'm good with this.
This is a-okay in my book.
The Bowser gauntlet has failed.
See, my thing was that I was just gonna wait around
until they got so bored that they all fell over.
And then I win.
Are these getting progressively more difficult?
It doesn't seem that way
but the way that the circles are darkening?
'Inside the Lava'
This sounds bad- oh no.
I just got horrible flashbacks to all of Ross' levels
Oh, much better!
Aw, I can't even get that, can I?
Oh, it's all just there to taunt me.
Thank you, I-I, I-I get it.
I get it. Man, no one likes water levels.
So slo-aah not that way.
So slow.
Alright, well that was fun, glad we did that...
J-j-just a time-gating mechanism to make yourself wait.
Oh god, we're going back in the water, aren't we?
We're just gonna bounce back and forth
between happy la-la water land, and then horrible lava.
Death.
Just, lava and deeaaugth.
Thank you.
HO! That was too much, don't even TRY to sass me like that!
AH! Oh!
[laugh] Jeez...
Oh my god, that was so scary!
Oh man.
Hoo boy.
Wow.
Not okay. [laughs]
I'm getting...
I-I am so scared.
I am so scared for what it wants to throw at me?
I am so scared- oooh, that's... not good.
I don't, where...
I...
I, I don't, I don't know where I'm going...
I, I don't know what I'm,
what I'm doing...
'Kay...
Okay.
That's, that's nice.
Okay. Cool.
[sobbing]
How am I gonna be able to get past the jets?
I don't have enough time!
I can't swim that fast!
Oh no.
Okay here we go, here we go
AHH! Oh god...
Okay, no checkpoints, this is a biiiitch
No you do not, no you do not!
No you do NOT!
What're you doing? What do I do? What do I do?
What do I do? What do I do?
Okay.
It's okay, okay. Okay.
Hoo!
WOOO!
Okay. Woo! Ah okay.
I know what I GOTTA DO! Yes.
Up here? Yes.
Okay, so far so goo...
HUUUP!
Okay. So far so goo!
[Strained noise]
What do I do? I dunno what to do!
What is this?
Aaak, what is this crap?
[Dog slobber noises]
Don't make any goddamn sense!
Okay. Alright then. That, was n-n-nuthin'.
What was the point?
OH! I can grab- oh! Th-
[high-pitched screaming]
FUUUUCK!
I can grab that spring, duh! I can grab that one!
AUGH!
All the way- [agonized yell]
All the way back!? But it was so difficult!
It wasn't difficult, but it was so slow!
Ahhhh bag of ass, I knew what I needed to do and I needed to do it!
[Aggravated noise]
What- No!
[Yodelling]
Oh god whyyy are you doing this to meeee~
Fuck a duck~
F- ahhh no!
COME ON!
NOOO! I got squooshed!
Okay. Now we got this.
I have no idea what to do with it, but I got it.
So that's good.
First step is getting the thing,
and then the next step will be using the thing
in the way that the thing is meant to be used.
And I don't know what that is.
Hoooly crap.
Okay, I lost that spring, is that spring just gone?
No, the spring's back over there.
I have a feeling I need that spring
But I don't know what for...
'Cause you can't climb with it, that's for sure.
You cannot climb with it.
So I, I imagine
The only thing that I can see is taking the leap of faith over this way.
Eugh!
Nope, that-
I don't know what it wants me to do!
Okay, I can't figure it out.
Skippin' it.
Oh my god, Ryan's gamepad is so gummed up with I don't know what
That I couldn't, I couldn't keep that pressed down.
So either way, I'm skipping that one. I could- I can't- I can't do, I can't do that one.
So, I'm gonna pick this up in the next episode because I tried real hard-
God, that is so sticky. What is in there??
I don't wanna know!
But thank you everybody so much for watching,
I'll try this again in another episode because I couldn't figure that out.
I just couldn't.
So thank you everybody again!
And as always,
I will see YOU in the next video.
Buh-bye!
[Outro music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]